foreign
[Music]
who are you
where are my manners
Sonic
meat knuckles
my new bffae
bestest friend forever and ever
look Robotnik I don't care who you
brought to help you you're never going
to get my power do I look like I need
your power
so nice when diabolical evil lives up to
the hype
where is it oh you want it
here it comes I was expecting more of
you you're unskilled
untrained
and unworthy
I forgot one Unstoppable
[Music]
it is my destiny to do what my ancestors
could not to restore the ultimate power
to the home of my people
ultimate power
working about you've got the wrong guy
now you speaky my language
don't play dumb with me Apprentice of
long claw you knew long claw long claw
and her people were the sworn Enemy of
My Tribe the Echidna we fought and died
at their hands and now you will die at
mine
true
come on get in I'm on your side I'm
sorry who are you
you know what it doesn't matter
get us out of here
he's got rabbit
gross
[Music]
make sure to get your shot tag man